who's under here
no more bunny business that's the line
we worked on do you guys like it okay
thank you for joining us easter bunny
oh
kelly
coming with the fire today i like it
okay um
okay a couple of items for you at the
top um happy tax day to those who
celebrate which we hope is everyone in
the room
as part of tax day we're highlighting
the real difference between the
president and congressional republicans
president biden has a simple philosophy
the middle class deserves some financial
breathing room which is why his economic
plan would give tax relief to tens of
millions of families families who work
hard and deserve a little extra cushion
each month and the president believes
billionaires should pay their fair share
so we can invest in our economic future
and cut the deficit that's why he's
calling on the top one percent of the
top one percent to pay a minimum tax of
20
when right now the wealthiest families
can pay a lower average rate than
teachers and let me be crystal clear the
president will not raise taxes for
anyone making under four hundred
thousand dollars the congressional
republican plan however as senator rick
scott outlined couldn't be more
different republicans on capitol hill
are more than happy to pass a nearly two
trillion dollar tax giveaway to the
wealthy and big corporations under the
previous they were under the previous
administration but now led by senator
scott republicans want to raise taxes on
the middle class with one independent
analysis showing their plan would hike
taxes by an average of around fifteen
hundred dollars each year on 75 million
american families ninety six percent of
whom make under one hundred thousand
dollars that's the plan of congressional
republicans tax hikes for the middle
class tax hikes for the wealthy and big
corporations president biden disagrees
it's time to put the middle class first
tomorrow as you may know the president
is traveling to new hampshire
to highlight infrastructure investments
to modernize our nation's ports and
waterways and discuss how these
investments will strengthen our supply
chain support local economies and help
cut costs for american families american
ports are a cornerstone
of the united states economy but
outdated infrastructure in the covid19
pandemic
have strained their capacity in
jeopardized global supply chains which
has caused delays and passed costs
directly to consumers thanks to the
bipartisan infrastructure law we now
have 17 billion dollars to upgrade
repair and maintain our nation's port
infrastructure as the president
continues to use every tool to help
bring down prices for americans
investments that strengthen domestic
supply chains and move goods faster and
more efficiently are critical to
lowering costs for families so during
his trip tomorrow he will visit
portsmouth harbor which is the only deep
water harbor in new hampshire and
handles approximately three point
million tons and nearly two billion
dollars of cargo a year including
critical materials to support the local
economy and clean energy production the
port recently completed a project to
widen the harbors turning basin and will
receive funding from the bipartisan
infrastructure law to maintain safe and
efficient operations along the channel
both crucial projects to accommodate
larger ships and heavier loads of cargo
also wanted to note a bunch of
scheduling things today today we are
pleased to announce that we will co-host
the second global 19 summit virtually on
may 12th alongside belize germany
indonesia and senegal the virtual summit
will redouble our efforts to end the
acute phase of the pandemic and prepare
for future pandemics and other health
threats our role in co-hosting the
summit continues to highlight is to
continue to highlight american
leadership in the global coveted
response with our provision to date of
more than 19 billion dollars in health
humanitarian and economic assistance and
our commitment to providing 1.2 billion
vaccine doses to the world for free of
which we've already delivered more than
500 million doses and while we are
dedicated to continuing to lead the
global coveted response we also need
congress to urgently do its part to fund
the global covet response we have
requested a supplemental funding package
for our most urgent needs to get shots
into the arms and to provide life-saving
tests treatments and supplies and we
will obviously continue to work with
congress on getting that funding when
they return finally i wanted to last
thing is that
we also announced that on march 12th and
13th the president will host the leaders
of the asean
in washington d.c it will build on
president biden's participation in the
october 2021 u.s asean summit where the
president announced 102 million dollars
in new initiatives to expand our
engagement with asean and kova 19
promoting economic growth and more and
this will of course
we'll have more to to preview as we get
closer to that trip joshua kick us off
thanks jen uh happy monday two minutes
subject areas
uh first a federal judge in florida says
the cbc exceeded its authority with the
mass mandate and airports that's the
white house decision the cdc recommended
continuing the order for additional time
two weeks to be able to assess the
latest science in keeping with its
responsibility to protect the american
people so this is obviously a
disappointing decision the cdc continues
recommending wearing a mask in public
transit as you know this just came out
this afternoon so right now the
department of homeland security who
would be implementing and the cdc are
reviewing the decision and of course the
department of justice uh would make any
determinations about litigation
secondly russia is expected to virtually
attend
meetings of the imf and world bank this
week
is that appropriate given the actions in
ukraine and how should international
organizations treat russia
well the president has made clear that
he does not believe we should be
operating as business as usual and he's
made clear about his concerns about
their participation in the g20 i'd also
note that our representative there the
secretary of treasury has made clear
that she isn't planning to attend uh
events or meetings that the russians are
participating in but in terms of other
determinations beyond that i don't have
any further comment
a question on this move to restart the
sale of leases for drilling on public
lands uh how long do you think it will
take for these new leases to actually
start producing and what impact do you
think this may have on gas prices
well let me first say that today's
action as you know but for everybody uh
was the result of a court injunction
that we continue to appeal and it's not
in line with the president's policy
which is to ban additional leasing
because uh one we need to move towards a
more clean energy economy which he
strongly believes in but also because
there are 9 000 permits on unused
on lands that could be tapped into by
oil companies and we don't feel they are
needed in terms of how long it will take
to get up uh drilling on because of the
court action i don't have any
assessments on that from here i would
just note that we are going to continue
to
fight this court injunction that is uh
forcing our hand and allowing this to
proceed even as we have taken actions to
reduce by 80 percent the areas to lease
and impose stringent environmental
standards the president has promised to
slash greenhouse gas emissions in half
by 2030.
now you're having to expand production
of fossil fuels when you promise to
curtail them congress as we know has yet
to act on many of your climate proposals
is the president's ambitious climate
change goal and agenda still attainable
or are these new leases going to
undercut that pledge well again these
leases are not in line with our policy
or the president's view um your you know
policy or not i mean this is the
situation that you're in it is and we're
going to continue there's there's
obviously we're going to continue to
fight uh this legal action um but i
would say that um you know the president
remains committed addressing the climate
crisis is one of the four pillars that
he came in he ran on as president and he
will continue to fight for
one of the reasons that this was so
troubling to him is because he is so
committed to
that
that objective as president and we
continue to propose have continued to
propose a historic investment in
addressing the climate crisis uh
something that we will continue to
discuss with congress so there are a lot
of ways to get there uh that we will
continue to work with congress to take
actions but he has also not hesitated to
take actions himself through his own
authorities to take actions to help our
climate so but are you still confident
that goal is achievable we are
continuing to pursue it and we are going
to continue to do everything we can to
reach it
go ahead
oh thank you house minority leader kevin
mccarthy is saying
president putin probably would have
backed off from invading ukraine if
president biden had shipped weapons to
ukraine sooner
does the president feel he should have
considered well first i mean just for
facts sake
we sent a record amount of security
assistance to ukraine during president
biden's first year in office more than
any other president uh in history
and we shared a significant amount of
intelligence with ukraine about russia's
intentions and military movements as you
all know because we've talked about in
here 3.2 billion total 2.6 billion since
this conflict started that's in direct
contrast with uh our predecessor who
withheld hundreds of millions of dollars
in military aid from ukraine including
javelins which mr mccarthy who was
critical of us in this moment defended
at the time as quote the rightful thing
to do because he claimed people believed
there was corruption in the zelinski
administration so i don't know if that's
a question for us as much as a question
for him what has changed in that period
of time and secondly are you planning
more sanctions this week on russia more
oligarchs what can you tell us
we are continuing to review and consider
additional sanctions
it's been an ongoing process but
right now you will still you will see us
continue to expand our sanctions targets
and to continue to take steps to both
further tighten our sanctions to to
prevent evasion and and put in place
additional sanctions i also wanted to
note a couple of comments for anyone who
questions which probably isn't anyone in
this room but maybe uh
whether these sanctions are having an
impact uh one is by the chairwoman of
the russian national central bank who
said these sanctions are quote will now
begin to increasingly affect the real
sectors of the economy and quote
practically every product she also said
that quote that sanctions are being
tightened almost every day and quote the
period during which the economy can live
on reserves is finite meaning these are
really having the squeeze that the
president the secretary of state
secretary of treasury treasury and
others have conveyed but we are
continuing to review and i expect we'll
have more in the coming days but just to
quickly follow up on the mask mandate
being voted by this judge what is the
white house's assessment of what that
means for travelers today
well it just happened this afternoon and
so the department of homeland security
is over obviously oversees uh the
implementation of this and they're
reviewing it as we speak so it's still
in place right now
they're doing it as we speak it just
came out this afternoon and if there are
any updates while i'm out here i'm sure
we can provide them to all of you okay
and president zielinski told jake tapper
yesterday that he wants president biden
to visit ukraine and he believes that he
will you said last week there were no
plans being made for president invited
to go is that still the case that has
not changed uh what our focus continues
to be on is providing ukraine the
ukrainian government ukrainian leaders a
historic amount of security assistance
assistance that's been adapted based on
their needs and their successes on the
grounds and obviously that can be
attributed largely to the courage and
the bravery of ukrainian leaders but but
the second reason is because of the
military assistance we provided i would
note because i know this is an
understandable question you all have
asked that
if anyone were to go there's no plans
for the president to go so let me just
reiterate that but uh we would not uh
outline from here or anywhere from the
government who if and when for security
reasons so we wouldn't have any details
to preview regardless is the president
considering granting president
zolinski's request to make russia a
state sponsor of terrorism
so that is a process that it's an
authority that obviously exists within
the government and at the state
department and
uh in order just broadly speaking uh for
uh for any country to be designated a
state sponsor of terror and there's only
three
uh north korea sudan and iran at this
point in time just for your full
perspective the secretary of state would
need to determine the government
government of that country has
repeatedly provided support for acts of
international terrorism and these of
course designations are made after a
careful review so while we have those
authorities
i don't have any update on that or
prediction of that that assessment would
be made by the state department what i
would note which i think is important is
that for the countries that have been
designated state sponsors of terrorism
so i named a couple of them for you
that the four main categories of
sanctions that result from designation
under these authorities include
restrictions on u.s foreign assistance a
ban on defense exports and sales certain
controls over exports of dual use items
and other financial restrictions and
what we've already done to date is of
course uh impose significant financial
sanctions export controls and curtailed
restrictions on financial assistance so
when you're thinking about
the impact these are already a lot of
steps that we've taken but i have
nothing to predict on that front that's
a that's a process that would have to be
reviewed through the state department
okay last question russia warned the
united states last week to stop arming
ukraine or risk unpredictable
consequences what is the the us believe
those consequences would be
well uh we're not going to um comment i
mean i'm not going to speculate on on um
empty threats or threats by president
putin or by russian leadership what we
have done here is done exactly what the
president said we would do from the
beginning which is to uh if they invaded
we would be providing significant
security assistance economics assistance
and support to the ukrainian people and
we're going to continue to do exactly
that
but i i want to belabor this only
because we've heard from the airlines
from airport passengers there may be
people sitting in an airport bar
watching right now wondering if they're
boarding a flight tonight is the mass
mandate still in place we're continuing
to recommend people wear masks i don't
have any update this just came out
through the courts just this afternoon
and as soon as there is an update uh we
will provide that is the white house
anticipating
an announcement by homeland security
tonight
they are assessing it right now and as
soon as they have an assessment and an
update on additional steps they'll
they'll make that available but if the
doj say doesn't stay the order tonight
or first thing tomorrow morning
our passengers
i understand why you're asking and
certainly no one here is trying to
provoke uncertainty with passengers we
also think the masked mandate should be
in place and that it's safer for
individuals who are flying to continue
to wear masks so we would say to anyone
sitting out there we'd recommend you
wear masks on the airplane and then as
soon as we can provide an update from
here hopefully soon we'll provide that
to all of you two more related cdc
things in the ruling the judge said
that she accepts the cdc's argument that
masks limit kovitz spread
but that alone is not sufficient to
overcome what she concludes is a rule
that exceeds the agency's authority to
put it in place
the administration believes otherwise
right
otherwise we wouldn't have put it in
place to begin with so that potentially
is the crux of an appeal or an attempt
to stop well again i would leave that to
the department of justice but uh all
what we what we announced last week uh
was just a two-week extension in order
to have time to assess what we've all
seen is rising cases and and and make an
assessment recommendation uh with that
in mind so of course it's disappointing
there's another issue the cdc is in the
middle of that's uh troubling some
democrats and that is of course the
impending end of title 42.
uh gary peters who chairs the homeland
security
committee another democratic senator
today suggesting
uh he has doubts about ending title 42.
um says that secretary mayor is
scheduled to be there for a budget
hearing i believe later this month or
next month
what more though is the administration
sharing
with these democrats
and republicans but notably a handful of
democrats who say they don't see a firm
plan they want more details
and the administration seems to be
rushing into this with no sense of what
the repercussions could be well i i
think it's important to remember this is
not an immigration authority um for
anyone who has concerns about it nor is
it an immigration plan they've never
said it was
it is a health authority that congress
gave the cdc authority to make a
determination about about whether it
needs to stay in place or not there is
no question we have a broken immigration
system there's more we need to do
we've been saying that from the first
day the president took office and anyone
who wants to work on that democrats
republicans anyone how we can put
smarter security in place how we can
have an asylum processing system that
works we would love to do that but what
they're what is happening right now is
they're essentially holding hostage
funding for covid and we're going to run
out of funding we're already running out
of funding for key programs so our issue
here is let's move forward with the
covet funding we're happy to have a
discussion about the broken immigration
system we agree it's broken let's work
together on addressing that say that
because there's this amendment to the
code that would put it i'd say because
that's the root issue here isn't it i
mean anyone who's raising concerns
they're tying it to
uh they're tying it to the coveted
funding
republicans are but you get a handful of
democrats who aren't necessarily i
understand that but but we're also happy
to work with anyone on on immigration
reform and any concerns they have but it
sounds like the answer is
if you've got concerns you congress do
something about it well
here's what happens on may 25th once the
president put forward a bill his first
day in office
it's not you do something about it let's
work together on it and we're happy to
do that you have different ideas you
want to talk about how to move this
forward let's do that at the same time
what's happening is this coveted funding
which means people who are uninsured are
not going to be able to get access
to
uh treatments to vaccines we're going
we're not going to be able to get the
fourth booster shot to everybody we're
not going to be able to get uh the um
treatments for immuno compromised so
that's where we're at and that's why
it's important to move that funding
forward and yes our system is broken
let's address it but this is a health
authority not an immigration authority
thank you jen
you said about this mass ruling out of a
federal court in florida that it's a
disappointing decision and you say you
continue to recommend that people wear
masks
why is it that we can sit here in the
white house briefing room with no masks
but people
can't sit in an airplane cabin with no
masks well peter i'm not a doctor you're
not a doctor that i'm aware of if you're
a doctor i wasn't aware of that today
until today
okay not a doctor just making sure i
don't know um
nor does he play one on tv there you go
most days um but these determinations
remember the masking guidance is there
are is green yellow and red we are
currently in a green zone in washington
dc so they're not recommending it some
people can still wear a mask if they
want to many people do or wear them in
meetings or wear them at certain times
where you're going to be around or
sitting close to people or maybe you
have an immunocompromised parent or or
friend and so people make that decision
and there's this is based on health
considerations and data that the cdc
looks at about transmissibility as as
we've seen increasing cases on on
airplanes and would the president's
support
if a flight is leaving from an airport
in a green zone those people don't have
to wear masks again peter there's a
there's been long a difference from the
beginning about people on a airplane and
in federal transportation vehicles and
situations than where they are in
locations like we here here continue to
be in washington d.c a green zone but
what we'd ask for i think it's important
to remember is a two-week extension or
not asked for what we had announced was
a two-week extension to look at the data
and make recommendations based on the
data on the science about whether it
should be continued or not okay on a
different topic we have new reporting
that at least 23 people apprehended at
the southern border in 2021 are on the
terror watch list
why do you guys think it is that
somebody on a terror watch list would
want to get into the united states
undetected
well i can't make an assessment of that
but what i can tell you is that your
data you're citing here means the border
patrol was doing their job i mean they
they apprehended people at the border
2000
illegal immigrants a day
got away last month are you saying that
you can say with certainty none of them
are on a terror watch list here's what
we're talking about encounters we know
and of suspected terrorists attempting
to cross the southern border they're
very uncommon we're talking about a few
dozen annual encounters that most at
most and these encounters represent
significantly less than the 0.01 percent
of total encounters per fiscal year in
recent years but i'd note these
individuals these 23 people the border
patrol they stopped them they prevented
them from getting into the country
they're protecting our homeland and
keeping us safe so the president is not
worried about
holes in the southern border being
exploited by people trying to come in
and kill americans he's grateful to the
border patrol for doing their job and
and stopping these people and preventing
them from getting into the country one
additional question about something that
happened a few months ago down at the
border we've been told that the mounted
border patrol officers president accused
of whipping migrants have been notified
they will not face criminal charges so
when is the president going to apologize
to that
there is a process and an investigation
that's gone through the department of
homeland security i don't have any
update on that the president said that
they were whipping people which would be
a criminal offense and they've been told
they're not going to be criminally and
there was an investigation into that and
i'll let the department of homeland
security announce any conclusion of that
investigation you accuse these officers
of brutal and inappropriate measures now
that they've been told they will not be
criminally charged will you apologize
and peter there was an investigation
into their behavior so that
investigation is playing out
whenever there it's going to be
announced the department of homeland
security will announce that and i'm sure
we'll have a comment on it after that go
ahead uh back on the mask issue as the
debate is going on about next steps is
there any concern in the white house
that this issue now that there are some
americans who are aware of this ruling
by the florida judge that it could
prompt some of the tensions we've seen
on airplanes in recent months until
there's a resolution yeah kelly it's a
great question obviously what we're
trying to do what we would encourage is
calm in all cases and because this
ruling just came out this afternoon i
know the objective of everybody involved
and all the necessary authorities in
government is to make a determination
about next steps as quickly as possible
so
that's certainly our hope and we want to
do everything we can to prevent that on
the oil leases um
does the president see any secondary
benefit to the fact that even though
this is not his policy objective that
there could be some
additional production that could help
given the fact that gas prices are high
and there has been a push to have
additional production because of the war
in ukraine even though it's not his
policy objective
i can tell you from talking with him
about this this morning uh he does not
um he believes that
as he announced and he remains committed
to the ban he called for on the
expansion of uh of leasing on federal
lands uh in part because he wants to
move toward a clean energy economy and
he's very committed to that and address
climate change but also because there's
9 000 unused leases that can be tapped
into and used um and we certainly have
encouraged oil companies to do that to
help address exactly as you said the
need to get more supply in the
marketplace does he see this move by the
department of
interior as
a
uh
going against his campaign pledge
well he sees he knows that it was the
result of a court injunction as you
heard uh secretary holland say and so it
was uh her hands were tied in many ways
as they can be by legal uh by legal
requirements but what they did which he
certainly supported was take steps to
reduce by 80 percent the areas to lease
and they also imposed stringent
environmental uh safeguards in order to
take additional steps even as the court
injunction uh
made them take these steps you did not
mention cuba as a state sponsor of
terror should we read into that i did
not mean to not mention them i wanted to
cite some examples just to give people a
sense of how few there are and what
kinds of countries i wasn't meant to
i'm not announcing new policy no i'm not
i'm not announcing new policy i just
wanted to give an indication of what
that is and how how limited the number
of countries are go ahead thank you um
this is a question that comes from one
of my colleagues who's reporting in
ukraine right now he is wondering
you know his conditions in mario pool
continue to disintegrate the united
states considering any
creative ways to help the ukrainians who
are under siege for instance
sending in third country planes or
planes from a neutral organization like
the red cross to get relief in that
so uh you mean humanitarian relief um
we are engaged with surrounding
countries with aid organizations about a
range of ways to get aid and assistance
in and obviously uh from the start of
this if there was if there was an
allowance or an implementation of these
humanitarian corridors it would have
helped enable um but we can't talk about
a lot of those things from here but we
are going to continue to take steps to
provide humanitarian assistance in every
way that we can i would note you didn't
ask this question but just one other
little update there were four uh planes
uh that arrived of military assistance
over the course of the weekend
another one to d is supposed to arrive
today if it hasn't already
from the 800 million package the
president announced so just to give you
a sense of our efforts to continue to
get more
assistance in and completely unrelated
but today on a background call about
climate policy an administration
official said that the white house is in
touch with a wide range of members of
congress about a reconciliation package
so are negotiations ongoing for build
fact better or building a better america
or whatever you're calling it now and
are you talking about it
we are talking about it um whatever you
call it a reconciliation package
including uh getting a historic
investment in climate including lowering
the cost of child care elder care
in healthcare taking all these steps
that the president has been committed to
these conversations have been ongoing uh
over the course of the last several
months and are those is joe manchin
involved in those conversations who are
you talking to we're talking to
everybody across the board i'm not going
to name all the names but they're all
included democrats across the board uh
who want to get this done
go ahead um is the u.s moving any closer
to reopening its embassy and keep now
that spain is joining france italy and
others in doing so
well certainly that's our objective um
is to open it but what we um what we are
evaluating is
obviously security considerations and uh
when the state department is prepared to
do that um so when we look at kind of
who should go first and how many and how
many people and when but it's all done
through the state department um and they
make those initial recommendations about
when to return but that certainly is our
objective obviously having a diplomatic
presence on the on the ground is
important just one more thing and
president zielinski says the russians
have begun their offensive to take
control of eastern ukraine what is the
administration's assessment of what's
happening there now
uh well i know that my defense
department colleague just did a briefing
so i'd really point you to the
department of defense for any kind of
on-the-ground updates
glenn um yesterday on cbs senator [ __ ]
said that without the west uh coming
more forcefully to ukraine's aid he said
quote i deeply worry that we will see
ukraine turn into syria does the
president share that concern
that's not uh words or phrase the
president would use or we would use from
from the united states obviously what
we've seen to date is the ukrainians
bravely fight back against the russians
and win essentially the battle of kiev
and continue to fight back against uh
their efforts across the country we've
known and predicted that they would move
their ground game uh to eastern ukraine
which is exactly what they've done and
we also have known and predicted and
when when jake sullivan was here uh just
a week or two ago he also conveyed that
uh they were like that moscow was likely
to launch air and missile strikes across
ukraine to cause military and economic
damage that's what we're seeing in lavee
and other and other places at this point
in time but uh what we've seen
i think is is them behave uh bravely
with huge courage and they have uh they
have had the success in pushing back
against the russians because of that but
also because of the military's
assistance provided by the united states
so no we would not share that assessment
on the diplomatic front um is the
administration any closer to naming an
ambassador to ukraine i certainly
understand the question i don't have any
update on that at this point from here
go ahead thanks john um i want to ask
about a story some of my colleagues
reported earlier today
um some allies of former president trump
have been pressing for state houses
around the country to pass resolutions
we're sending electoral college votes
for president biden and to bring
lawsuits that seek to prove baseless
claims of large-scale voter fraud
um legal experts have called this effort
preposterous but is an organized push
among those allies to certify the last
election something this administration
is monitoring or concerned about
uh well i would say that there have been
dozens of uh of court cases uh that have
uh not been won by our predecessor and
people who support him in an effort to
overturn the outcome of the last
election um and our focus is on
governing for the american people
delivering for the american people uh
and less on focusing on what he and his
people are up to
go ahead yeah thanks jen i wanted to
follow up on the question earlier
regarding senator kuhn's comments yeah
one of the uh points he was making was
that the u.s needs to have a
conversation about sending
u.s troops to ukraine he told based
nation yesterday uh quote the american
people cannot turn away from this
tragedy in ukraine i think the 21st
century turns on how fiercely we defeat
freedom in ukraine and that putin will
only stop uh when we stop him uh what's
the white house's response to this
suggestion for the senator that the u.s
needs to start having a conversation
about maybe sending troops to ukraine
and does the president agree that uh
putin will stop
when we the u.s
only when we the u.s stop him
well what i would say is one senator
coons is a close friend of the
presidents and the administration and we
disrespectfully disagree with his
proposal
the president continues to
has no plans to send troops to fight a
war with russia he doesn't think that's
in our national security interests in
the interests of the american people and
so what our focus has been on has been
obviously providing this historic amount
of security assistance military
assistance weapons to the ukrainians
that has helped them effectively fight
this war and economic assistance as well
this is also strengthening their hands
at the negotiating table even while we
are putting in place a historic package
of economic sanctions that as i noted
earlier even the head of the russian
central bank is noting the devastating
impact of these sanctions on the russian
economy so that has been our strategic
focus um of course we support the
ukrainians
in every way possible but the president
is not going to fight a war with russia
but
um the president has done or will do a
lot of travel in recent days two places
yeah so-called house frontliners are
running for re-election and i wanted to
know if you could talk about how much um
political considerations are weighed or
taken into consideration on the white
house's side from the president and also
if uh what kind of an impact do you
think if any will is discussion and
promotion of things like the
infrastructure law will have on voters
as well
well i'm always careful about what i get
into about politics from up here i've
learned my lesson um but what i will say
is that um the president is proud to go
out in the country in blue states red
states purple states
to talk about his agenda both what he
has achieved including the bipartisan
infrastructure law that is rebuilding
roads rails and bridges and uh and uh
and replacing uh lead pipes around the
country expanding broadband access
across the country in communities no
matter what your political party is and
he's also proud to go out and talk about
his uh his economic agenda he's still
fighting to get past which includes
child care health care um elder care and
reducing costs and his view is that for
anyone out there um when they're out
there uh
senators or or members of congress who
are going to be talking to their
communities that standing up for his
agenda and standing up for this agenda
that will make the american people's
lives better is a is a winning argument
so i would say um
i wouldn't i'm not going to overly note
the the political sway of districts or
states but he's always said he wants to
be the president for all people governed
for all people and that means talking
about his agenda in red blue and purple
states
go ahead
jennifer going back to coronavirus um
some of us recently here and around the
country have been taking home tests to
diagnose ourselves um
and when those come up positive those
aren't always reported to public health
and sometimes they can't be sometimes
they won't even accept that
do you believe that we have an accurate
sense of the spread of the coronavirus
right now well i think what's important
to remember is that um one cd what how
cdc uh continues to track covet cases
that are reported they do it really
through hospitalizations and death um
and those numbers around severe disease
come directly from hospitals and states
and what we're seeing through those
is that we're at the lowest level
hospitalization since the start of the
pandemic i believe we're still at that
point in time so we certainly encourage
people to share their test results and
contact their doctor because they may be
eligible for pex lovid or or any other
therapeutics um but you know beyond that
as i think i would note when we put out
the president's 100-page plan we noted
that our focus was really on
hospitalizations deaths and severe cases
uh even as we're encouraging people to
report testing for contact tracing and
other purposes uh when they test
positive untitled 42 there is a
bipartisan group of senators including
cinema mansion
some who are at risk including senator
kelly who say who are proposing the idea
of letting the surgeon general certify
when the public health emergency has
ended is that something the president
would consider and then why or why not
well the seat congress gave the cdc the
authority uh so uh
and i'm wondering if you're open to that
idea well i don't have any projection
prediction of that at this point the cdc
is the public health authority for the
country so i don't i don't i don't have
any more predictions for that go ahead
um japanese prime minister kishida just
announced japan taking in a group of
refugees which is really a big deal for
japan and the foreign minister hayashi
flew back a group of
refugees from poland to japan his
administration aware of that and and
then also uh with the trip to japan next
uh month uh any update on whether an
interview with the
president is unlocking
uh oh it's an interview pitch okay um
i said oh an interview with whom um i i
like your style um
uh we we certainly welcome and applaud
um the actions of um of the uh the the
of japan the japanese leadership um and
are grateful to
uh their steps in taking in refugees and
their humanitarian support through this
conflict um and they're an important
partner as you know um uh and uh have
been a part of important meetings uh on
the conflict in ukraine in recent months
including on the president's last trip
to europe um i will certainly take under
advisement your request go ahead eugene
thanks jen um there have been kind of a
growing growing rumblings among economic
economists about the r word recession on
that coming position
i was like where are we going with this
yes um and i guess i'm just curious how
the administration is feeling the
possibility of that and what kind of
conversations are happening right now
about a possible recession well we
continue to believe our economist most
importantly that the united states
economy will deal with challenges ahead
from a position of strength because of
the president's economic plan it's
important to remember we created more
jobs last year than any other year in
history we obviously have a very low
unemployment rate in the country and
we've seen wages go up in a number of
areas i would note that there was a
goldman sachs we may be referring to
this the goldman sachs analysis
and even in their analysis they said
quote we still do not see a recession as
inevitable however particularly since
the fed's goal of cooling the economy
while avoiding a recession will be
helped by postcovid normalizations in
labor supply and durable goods prices so
our view is we're in a period of
historic uh job growth strong business
investments strong consumer and business
balance sheets and normalizing supply
chains those are all good signs for the
economy but obviously we'll continue to
monitor uh any any concerns we have
about where things are headed then if
inflation continues to rise uh what are
the concerns about that it feels about
making a lot well the federal reserve
continues to project that it will
moderate uh by the end of the year uh
and they obviously we support uh their
steps they've announced to recalibrate
um and we've already seen some of those
actions taken uh but really that it's
under their purview uh so we would point
to their projections
uh so just a follow up on title 42 the
issue that democratic senators have
brought up is that there isn't a
detailed plan they think to to deal with
the expected rise in migrants at the
border so does the white house feel
confident that the administration has
the necessary resources and operational
plan in place to process and house and
transport
well i would i would point to the fact
that the department of homeland security
put out a plan that they briefed members
on uh when we announced the timeline or
the implementation period an extended
period that wasn't immediate
um at the time uh that includes surging
resources and making sure we had uh the
type of resources available
to meet any needs
so they did put out a preparedness plan
at the time but we're going to have
continuing conversations and we
certainly welcome any engagement to do
that our issue is more the hooking it
with covet funding because of the
devastating impact that would have on
communities across the country
just
another question on um a times op-ed
that senator warren uh wrote today
saying that democrats need to deliver on
more of their agenda in order to keep
the majorities in congress
do you agree with that promise and at
this point i know you named a few of the
legislative priorities already in the
briefing but
are there top three priorities that the
white house feels they can actually get
done before the midterms
we love all of our children in the
legislature around here um what i will
say is that um you know we've talked a
bit about
steps to lower costs which i know
senator warren of course strongly
supports as well for child care for
health care for elder care
for prescription drugs these are
no-brainers for most people in the
country and also making the tax system
more fair we think those are all issues
that democrats but also a lot of people
around the country would love for us to
do more on and love to talk about more
um we of course as i've stated a couple
times in this briefing want to get coved
funding because we think it's essential
so that we can continue a lot of the
programs that have had such a huge
impact on people's lives including for
the uninsured including uh
making sure we have boosters for fourth
boosters for every american who wants
them whenever people are eligible
including being able to buy enough evas
sheld and for end treatments for the
immuno compromise that's hugely
important to us um and then of course we
um we want to get the innovation act
passed because we believe that
that's something that should have
bipartisan support and
we want to make sure we have
manufacturing here in the united states
something that can make us stronger over
the long term there are many other
things but i would say those are a
couple of the things that we will
continue to fight to move forward with
the premise that that the administration
and uh democrats in congress need to get
more done in order to have a shot at the
majority i would say i'm not going to
make political predictions from here
what i will say though is that um
everybody looks at a choice and what
each
party is fighting for is advocating for
has gotten accomplished but also what
their vision is for the future and we're
proud of our vision
to go back to the virtual covet summit
yes mentioned again the need for
congress to recruit coveted funding does
the white house see that date may 12th
for the summit as a deadline for
congress to get that funding approved we
don't but we just see it as a reminder
of how important it is um that to uh to
continue to take steps to be the
provider the va the arsenal vaccines to
the world something we have already done
uh since the since the last summit um
while the world has made significant
progress in scaling up vaccination
efforts and kova and kovacs has now
provided almost 1.2 billion vaccines to
more covax yes it's more than 140
countries uh with 88 of those
contributions going to low and middle
income countries we're not at the global
vaccination rate that we need to be or
that
health experts project we we want to be
at right it's a 70 vaccination target
that's the global target set by the
world health organization and while
vaccination rates are rising only
approximately 20 percent of countries
are fully vaccinated at least at least
70 percent of their population but this
is an opportunity obviously we're going
to continue to fight for more funding
here but we will to continue to press
other countries to do more uh to help
the world make progress as well and
along those lines um you know we've
heard usaid chief samantha power say
earlier this month that if there isn't
that global coveted funding if congress
put something together about it that the
u.s would have to turn its back on the
countries that need urgent help to boost
vaccination rates will it be difficult
for the u.s to take a lead at a summit
like that if that funding has not come
through well we are far and away the
leader in the world that will not change
between now in the summit regardless of
funding however we want to continue to
be and continue to be providing not just
vaccine doses but also the know-how and
equipment and supplies that countries
around the world need more mass
shootings this past weekend more mass
shootings two teenage boys dead
dozens injured
what does the president believe is
causing such a callous disregard for
human life in this country
well let me first say and thank you for
the question um these shootings are
horrific and must stop our prayers are
with the survivors those who are lost
and their families i can't attribute
obviously these this just happened over
the weekend the reasoning um but what i
can tell you is that it's a reminder of
the need to take more steps to stop gun
crime something the president has
strongly supported and advocated for
since uh for decades in public office
cracking down on gun traffickers putting
more cops on the beat investing
community anti-crime programs and of
course also confirming
a very qualified individual steve
dedleback to uh to lead the atf
what does the president have in mind if
anything a plan to improve to
to
to get people to respect life form to
respect other human beings laws aside
you can't legislate morality or values
right human life
does they ever talk about that openly to
you or anyone else i think every time
that you've seen the president talk
about uh shootings the impact on
families on human beings
on loved ones on communities
he talks about that human impact and but
it also is true that in order to reduce
and change the direction of crime and
gun crime which is the majority of crime
we need to change we need to have more
laws in place go ahead well thank you
texas governor abbott said that quote
financial pain was necessary to get
officials to take action on illegal
immigration
um is there any sense that those border
inspections did cause financial pain
that there was any disruption just
supply chain or anything like that that
you are tracking well while i don't have
an extended summary um summary analysis
uh what i do know is that you don't have
to look farther than the comments made
by business leaders trade organizations
of all political stripes and parties and
their opposition to the unnecessary uh
additional
steps that the governor was implementing
and there's one million dollars
in trade crossing over the u.s mexico
border every minute so there's no
question that uh putting these
unnecessary inspections in place which
resulted at the time in the drop in
commercial traffic of up to 60 to 70
percent in some ports was having a huge
impact on the local community on
businesses and that's why so many people
were so outspoken about it and just
quickly yeah do you have an update on
the plan for ukrainian refugees will it
be a parole program like you have for
afghans
yeah i certainly understand the question
and i don't have any update in this
moment that's exactly the type of
program but there are a lot of
considerations so hopefully we'll have
more soon go ahead thank you jen does
president biden have confidence in
senator dianne feinstein steve con
senator dianne feinstein yes he's she's
a longtime friend a proud public servant
and someone he has long enjoyed serving
with and working with after that report
came out last week questioning your
health did the president reach out to
her i don't have any updates on private
conversations
thanks everyone
you